[Música]
no
si tuviera que elegir
/ respirar o amarte
utilizaría mi último suspiro
para decirte que te amo quieres casarte
conmigo
esta es una frase
clarísimamente persuasiva o que pretende
persuadir
pretende que alguien haga algo
tengo otra
tengo otra muy popular que se ha
traducido a
cientos de idiomas y que a todos oa
prácticamente todos nos ha persuadido
alguna vez dice así a ver cómo sale
pague dos y llévese tres
a todos nos ha persuadido esto alguna
vez estamos rodeados de persuasión
rodeados de mensajes que pretenden
persuadir nos y de mensajes con los que
pretendemos persuadir al final la
persuasión es la habilidad de convencer
a alguien mediante argumentos racionales
y emocionales para que se comporte de
una forma determinada
yo para hablar de persuasión y para
intentar explicar la utilizó una fórmula
una fórmula con tres suman dos y los
tres suman dos son sine quanon los tres
deben cumplirse para que se perfeccione
el proceso de la personación y eso
sumando son atención memoria y
comportamiento
atención para que escuchen el mensaje
memoria para que lo recuerden y
comportamiento para que actúen en
consecuencia
bien vamos con la primera parte de esta
fórmula los dos primeros sumandos
atención y memoria y aquí vamos a echar
mano de la psicología o de la
neuropsicología o de los resultados de
la neurociencia
hay una frase que me gusta mucho de los
neuropsicólogos que dice
sin emoción no hay atención y sin
atención no hay memoria
porque resulta resulta que la emoción es
relevante para nuestro cerebro resulta
que la emoción es una herramienta
a partir de la cual nuestro cerebro se
adapta a los constantes cambios y
amenazas del entorno
la emoción es capaz
de romper las barreras de la atención y
de retener
durante mucho tiempo los recuerdos en el
caprichoso archivo de nuestra memoria me
gustaría hacer una pequeña prueba
os voy a pedir por favor que os
levantéis todos los que sepáis
exactamente lo que comiste es el pasado
miércoles
no fue una comida muy emocionante
segunda pregunta
os voy a pedir por favor que os
levantéis todos los que sepáis
exactamente
donde pasaste es el primero los dos
primeros días del confinamiento de esta
pandemia del comit 19
eso sí fue emocionante gracias muchas
gracias eso sí fue emocionante
y lo vais a recordar toda la vida
y cuando de aquí diez quince veinte
treinta años vengan vuestros nietos
abuelo abuelo abuela abuela oye mira lo
que pone el libro de historias que pasó
en el 2020 me cuentas
les diréis venid venid sé que tenéis
tiempo venid venid os voy a contar una
bonita y larga historia
y gracias a esta fuerza
de las emociones que nos deja grabado
recuerdos en la cabeza les contaremos
que es el gel hidroalcohólico que si las
mascarillas que si la ciudad vacía y bla
bla
entonces si las emociones llaman la
atención y fijan los recuerdos en la
memoria
un mensaje
emocional y emocional izamos nuestros
mensajes
nuestro interlocutor
evocará el mensaje a partir del recuerdo
de la emoción y con esto ya tenemos una
parte de la fórmula bastante solucionada
atención y memoria
falta una cosita falta una cosita que es
la percepción
realmente el mensaje recordado la
esencia del mensaje recordado es el que
nosotros hemos transmitido
porque lo que está claro es que no todos
percibimos los mismos estímulos de la
misma forma basta recordar y os
acordaréis todos de aquel meme del del
traje del vestido que era blanco y
dorado o azul y negro es brutal yo lo
utilizo en mis charlas
mismo estímulo misma imagen mismas
condiciones atmosféricas mismas
condiciones de luz
la platea se divide hay una parte que ve
el vestido blanco y dorado y hay otra
probe azul y negro mismo estímulo
diferentes percepciones
cómo solucionamos esto pues preguntando
escucha activa escuchemos al presunto
persuadido a nuestro interlocutor
escuchémosle atentamente su comunicación
verbal y su comunicación no verbal sus
emociones preguntemos hasta que estemos
seguros de que la esencia del mensaje
que ha recibido es el que le hemos
transmitido y ya tendremos atención y
memoria solucionado falta el
comportamiento importante y resulta que
perseguimos un comportamiento voluntario
estamos hablando de persuasión no
hablamos de manipulación la manipulación
está basada en parte en el engaño y eso
hace que su efecto sea muy efímero
nosotros queremos persuadir con objetivo
a corto a medio y a poder ser a largo
plazo por lo tanto necesitamos que
nuestro interlocutor quiera
voluntariamente ir hacia ese destino que
le estamos proponiendo y aquí entra otro
elemento
es la motivación
dicen los psicólogos que la motivación
son es ese impulso que nos empuja a
actuar oa comportarnos de una forma
determinada y persistir en ese
comportamiento hasta su culminación
hasta que alcanzamos la meta
dicen también que hay dos tipos de
motivación la motivación intrínseca y la
motivación extrínseca la primera es
aquella en la que hacemos algo bueno por
nosotros mismos por nuestra autoestima
por sentirnos más realizados por el
orgullo porque somos más felices no sé
yo tengo una sobrina que desde los 5
años desde muy pequeñita quiere ser
médico está estudiando bachillerato
ahora y sabe que para entrar en medicina
necesita una nota de bachillerato
altísima porque si no no puede entrar y
estudia muchísimo estudia muchísimo
porque es consciente
de que de poder acceder a la facultad de
medicina depende una parte importante de
ese modelo que tiene ella de felicidad
en la cabeza
motivación intrínseca es buena
la motivación extrínseca es la del palo
la zanahoria y el burro
es la aquella en la que nos comportamos
de una forma determinada
porque esperamos obtener la recompensa
que tenemos prometida si nos comportamos
así otro sobrino mío no tan buen
estudiante
ese sobrino estudia
estudia pensando en la proposición que
le han hecho sus padres si apruebas todo
en junio bicicleta nueva el tipo es un
loco de la bici de montaña bueno esto le
motiva esto le motiva bueno motivación
extrínseca es verdad que la motivación
intrínseca es más potente es más
duradera funciona mejor pero es difícil
que yo compre una plata más de atún para
sentirme más realizado
vale 2 y en ese 3 eso sí funciona
bien ya tenemos
las emociones que activan la atención y
la memoria la percepción que que chequea
que ese mensaje transmitido es en
esencia el que queríamos transmitir y la
motivación que va a llevar al
comportamiento ahora ya sólo falta una
un detalle que podríamos enmarcarlo
dentro de lo que son las habilidades
personales
conozcamos perfectamente a nuestro
interlocutor
si sabemos cómo piensas y sabemos cómo
sientes y sabemos cuál es su cultura si
sabemos que le gusta y que le disgusta
nos será muchísimo más fácil seleccionar
ese código de comunicación
que nos va a hacer match que nos va a
empatar que nos va a comunicar
lancemos mensajes sencillos mensajes
claros
presionemos a nuestro interlocutor a
nadie le gusta ser presionado
seamos honestos no mintamos al que
miente se le nota de forma consciente o
no consciente pero se le nota y nadie
quiere hacer nada con un mentiroso
no tengamos miedo a que nos digan que no
dicen que no no pasa nada pero a la
gente no le gusta relacionarse con gente
insegura prefiere gente segura y por
último muy importante
que nuestro aspecto nuestra comunicación
no verbal nuestros gestos nuestro tono
no contradigan nuestro mensaje en
comunicación la parte más importante del
mensaje la transmite la comunicación no
verbal no la palabra la comunicación no
verbal que no nos contradiga
la persuasión al final eso es un proceso
en donde todo es de sentido común
pero es un proceso complejo porque todos
los elementos que conforman el proceso
de la persuasión se han de dar sí o sí y
si falla uno ya no conseguiremos esa
personación final ese comportamiento
final que buscamos
a partir de aquí si habéis entendido
este proceso que yo creo que es como
decía de mucho sentido común
y os observáis y observáis a los demás
como persuaden y sois persuadidos
mañana
seréis mejores persuasores y mañana
también seréis persuadidos mucho más
críticos
y si no no pasa nada
en cualquier caso pagaréis 2 y os
llevaréis 3 muchas gracias
[Aplausos]